you told me i'm going to change my song
no i did not say that
muhammad are you going to choose a
bikini over me yes if i were her i would
muhammad and eve get into a huge fight
after she resists his attempts to mold
her into a muslim woman including
telling her to change her clothes he
didn't approve of my outfit and while
this is so obvious
i'm just gonna say it
these two are not compatible
they're just not muhammad is a 25 year
old muslim guy who wants free spirited
eve to act like his mom my perfect woman
in my imagination is
that women will love me as my mother
but then he wants to tell this 48 year
old woman what she can and cannot do
i'm so confused why are they doing this
we're gonna talk about it plus are you
nervous uh
no no no yeah he's lying
i'm not sure if it was the nerves or
what but during bingham's first time
meeting ari siblings he tells them he
wants ari to help him get a green card
regardless if they work out or not
because
it's good for me
and that lack of response says it all
this disapproving silence is so
[Music]
horribly strong yeah this wasn't
binyam's finest moment let's get into it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melisia
before we get into this week's episode i
have to talk about your takes on bilal
and chida last week
i looked at the comments and i was like
damn
almost every comment was going in on
belau
you say he's a narcissist controlling
emotionally abusive
the list goes on and i'm gonna be honest
it made me take a step back and ask
myself
am i missing something here because
although i don't think bilal is showing
up as his best in this relationship
i don't see him as this horrible person
but so many of you do
and whenever you feel so strongly about
something
i always step back and reassess
because remember this is a safe space
where people with different opinions can
have an honest conversation
that's what i love about y'all i was
planning on taking a look at some of
your comments and letting you know what
i think but shaida has spoken out and
i'm sure you'd rather hear from her in
this situation than me in a now deleted
instagram story shaida seemingly
responds to all the criticism bilal has
been receiving
writing quote for as long as i've known
bilal he has been a very sweet caring
sensitive kind-hearted soul who gives me
whatever i want and i'll do the same for
him
no he is not a narcissist
no he is not controlling because he is
muslim but because perception is reality
we have been conditioned to perceive a
black man as scared illiterate deadbeat
dependent and struggling if that's not
what we see then yes he has to be a
narcissist so let's destroy him and
humble him and remind him of what he has
to be
stop trying to defame him with
perceptions sit back and enjoy the show
i think some of the comments were so
harsh and
some of them were very distasteful so
i've seen he had a very difficult time
when i spoke with chad and bilal i asked
him how he feels about all the criticism
he's receiving
here's what he had to say yeah i've
gotten
phone calls i've gotten like emails i've
gotten
uh
the like the the stuff that
people say it's like wow i've never
experienced that before in my life and
it was just like
it was just eye-opening to see that
wow like
somebody can take like 10 20 minutes of
what they see
and
just
inform opinion about you like that so
that was kind of hurtful before we move
on but i do want to mention one comment
from eve she says quote i see no joy in
their interaction he is acting like a
disciplinary not good for couple them
and you might be on to something because
even though they went on a date this
week next week chada confronts bilal
about treating her like a child it is
compulsory for us men and women to learn
our religion what every time we have a
discussion
you give me a lecture
do you feel like it's election oh it's
high
when bella goes into lecturing mode i
feel to respond and say yes daddy no
daddy okay daddy you do 24 happen
you all i think it's time for us to talk
to shaida just a one-on-one conversation
what do you think yeah i think so let's
make it happen all right let's dive into
even muhammad's big fight just a
refresher last week he told her she
can't be around other men alone
i'm not a muslim woman but here was a
muslim man fast forward to this week eve
is taking muhammad to dinner so he can
meet her friends for the first time but
before they leave the house he tells her
what she's wearing
is inappropriate oh are you sure you're
going with this code
what's the matter
they can see your underwear
i can't see everything
okay well i can put another jacket on
all right i don't care
the cameraman was wrong for that now i
don't subscribe to a man telling a woman
what she should wear
but in a case like this
i can see why he asked her to put on a
longer jacket because you can totally
see her underwear clear as day i know
some people are okay with that but
personally
i think if she was going out with her
friends it could slide but because she's
going out with her man
beyond any religious rules
it's just a sign of respect but on the
flip side i totally get why it hurts her
feelings she steps out feeling confident
and he crushes that but i was kind of
annoyed that
he didn't approve of my outfit
i didn't think it was distasteful
when they get to dinner with eve's
girlfriends things take an uncomfortable
turn for muhammad to say the least my
first impression about eve's friends
that they are weird
i felt that they are trying to
see how i will react because i'm muslim
so
they
in purpose to show more of their boobs
and i don't need to see that
that's a bit of a self-centered
statement right there muhammad so we
have some questions for you is it okay
if we take it
eve's friends who seem right or die by
the way start grilling muhammad they ask
if he's ever been in a relationship
before and he reveals he was actually
engaged she broke up with me because i
don't have money well damn
for some reason i get the feeling that
muhammad is okay with not having money
maybe because he said he wants his woman
to take care of him
i don't know have you ever been intimate
with any other women
like had sex with any other women
as the conversation continues eve's
friends start to bring up sex and porn
and that rubs muhammad the wrong way how
did you know what to do then if you've
never no really like did you have you
ever watched porn
in egypt no one never will ask this kind
of coach
eve's friends then bring up muhammad
having an issue with eve wearing a
bikini
but remember when he first slid into her
dms her profile pic was a picture of her
wearing a bikini and her friends pointed
that out muhammad didn't say much in
response but eve makes it a moment to
bring up the whole change your clothes
situation
i was gonna wear a shorter jacket and
then
he was like your butt is gonna show
and every single one of her friends
went into straight protection mode
when men try to tell women what to wear
it's it's never in a in a positive way
like how you're saying if you're trying
to protect her it's more of controlling
i'm concerned that he's this controlling
tyrant
and i would hate for her just to
compromise to
a union that i think should accept you
fully as you are
are you very curious why you're judging
me they having their proofs hanging out
and they don't want anyone
judged there
but they
were judging me the entire time
and that's the showing how still they
are he really just called her friends
stupid
wow
how do y'all feel about eve telling her
friends about what happened between her
and muhammad before they left the house
i'm thinking she was still feeling bad
about it and she wanted to get it out
with hopes that they would make her feel
better and reassure her that she dresses
nice
but i was always taught not to be quick
to tell your friends what's going on
between you and your partner
because once she forgives muhammad and
lets it go those fierce warriors at the
table will not
which also isn't necessarily a bad thing
but it can cause her more stress
i respect your culture and the
difference
between here and egypt
but they didn't do the same on the way
home muhammad was obviously upset about
the lines eve's friends crossed during
dinner by bringing up porn and asking
him about sex but then he tells eve oh
i'm actually mad at you for telling our
business
when i told you my opinion about your
clothes that was private moment
between me and you eve then brings up
how her friend already knows about a big
fight they had months ago when she wore
a bikini on a family vacation instead of
a one-piece you told me i'm going to
change my song no i did not say that
muhammad
you changed what you agreed about in
this point and you take advantage of my
that's bs like i'm wearing a bathing
suit i don't have time to go run around
with my son in a pandemic to go find a
one-piece bathing suit i'm sick of being
judged myself too like i can't even put
on a dress that i think is nice without
you being like giving me a hard time
okay she should stop bringing up that
dress because in my opinion it's taking
away from her overall point you said
you're not going to wear a bikini
anymore
bikini that's why i got upset
after you said that you did it eve goes
on to reveal all the things she changed
about herself from muhammad she stopped
eating pork told him she would only
drink on special occasions
and she cleaned out her closet letting
go of things she knows he would
disapprove of
so she has made adjustments but why is
she the only one bending for her partner
someone who is not bringing home the bag
mind you
just telling her what she can and cannot
do
now i get that she signed up to marry a
muslim man but what doesn't make sense
to me is that muhammad is giving her all
these rules
but he's picking and choosing what rules
he wants to follow
remember muhammad is living with eve
one rule broken he's having sex with eve
another world broken
i know none of us are perfect but how
come she can't pick and choose what
rules she wants to follow if that's what
you're doing
that's just not fair you can dress
whatever you want drink wine or whatever
but don't get married
are you going to choose a bikini over me
yes at this point that bathing suit
symbolizes so much more eve seems like a
woman who at 48 loves who she is and is
embracing who she is which isn't always
an easy place to get to
plus losing the parts that you like
about yourself for somebody else
is never worth it i am not a muslim
woman
and
i don't want to be told what to do
i don't think that i go out looking
[ __ ] or anything like that i'm proud
of the way i look and i don't think that
i should feel
judged or ashamed for that and i don't
like to feel that from the person that
supposedly loves me eve grabs a pillow
and blanket and heads for the couch
leaving muhammad to sleep alone in the
bed for the night
in the perfect world muhammad would have
been the one on the couch but i guess
eva's being kind to her guest i'm not
gonna
live my life feeling controlled and
feeling like
i'm a bad person for just being who i am
as much as i love him i won't get
married if we can't like figure this out
i would love to know what she loves
about him and their relationship
i haven't seen a spark yet all right
let's move on to binyam and ari ari
can you please come on i don't want to
be late ari is taking bingham to dinner
with her family and he is anxious
because while he's met ari's parents he
hasn't met ari's siblings but they are
well aware of the pain he has caused
their sister and they waste no time
bringing it up last time
she was here and you guys were fighting
and i heard you guys fighting through
the wall what was going on
uh
uh i did a mistake i want busy myself
like i go friends even it's not my
friend can i meet you i want to busy
myself benniam is sticking with this
story i go like in the club like just i
want to forget past like something he
starts to tear up as he talks about the
fear of losing his family again i love
her so much i tell her i'm really sorry
because of
i'm doing this
i'm sorry
so
ari and mom take benny at his word so
you were afraid she wasn't coming back
yeah yeah
but her sister
she calls the bs
that sounds like a nice answer to tell
your future mother-in-law yeah
but is it true
yeah it's
just it's true because every time i ever
called you on the phone he wasn't there
yes this is sister love right here she's
not letting anything slide
or if you called me i think he was never
there
i'm like where's bingham oh he's out
okay
um she spoke the truth
and it looks like it hit home for ari
that moment makes me think of every time
i ignored the facts in a romantic
relationship
believe these stories made excuses just
because i wanted it to work
instead of looking at the person's
actions and accepting them
binyam likes to go out let the stories
go and just be honest benny
we gotta give a shout out to ari's
sister for pointing out the hard things
to her
as we've seen on 90 day in the past
everybody doesn't have that i want to
try like mma fighting binyam starts to
tell ari's family about his big dreams
and ari's mom finds the nicest way to
say
okay but how are you going to make this
money let's talk practical so benjamin i
have a question
who's paying the bills ari's parents are
so cute this is more expensive to live
here than an addis so i'm like thinking
he can't work you can't you're not
working
it's hard i wonder if ari wants to work
i don't know if she's saying it's hard
to find a job or if it's hard because
she likes her freedom it's hard
we have our concerns about their
sustainability together yeah she needs
to get a job too
first because he's not working
absolutely yeah
there's also the fact that this show is
basically both of their jobs at this
point but maybe that's too much to get
into on tv anyway bennium decides this
is a good time to tell ari's family
about another one of his dreams and he
excludes ari from it but don't worry her
sister
calls him out
[Music]
okay okay i'll stop i'm dreaming she
knows that
like even if i'm not with her i want to
be like an ufc fighter like maybe
championships that's why i'm dreaming
maximizing the debut so your major dream
is to be a ufc fighter yeah whether
you're with arie or not right is that
what you said okay is that why you're
here
everybody's laughing but nothing is
funny ari's mom janice goes on to ask
binyam if he's nervous
no no yeah he's lying
and then he says something that sounds
even worse than what he said before i
came for an arie but for my family they
tell me even ari if she don't want you
she can sign for you for a green card
because
it's good for me
why did he say that
this disapproving silence is so
horribly strong arya says she thinks
benny is having a hard time
communicating but i think her family
heard him clearly she admits to thinking
she loves binya more than he loves her
and she wonders if they will ever work
out their trust and communication issues
i'm the real prize here better than a
green card if i decided i want to marry
yeah me too yeah that didn't go too well
and next week binyam is about to find
himself in more trouble it's about to go
down
so you didn't think to tell me that you
would be training with a girl hey why is
he training with a girl this is my first
what's your name
hey melissa so you have full makeup on
usually get out of my way i tell you to
have enough you never told me that if
you're not gonna be honest about what
you're doing and then listen
ari didn't care if that woman was a ufc
fighter she said get out of my way get
out of my way and looking at this shot
with binyam and the woman i'm not gonna
lie i would have felt some way too
what is this foreplay it was a bit much
all right 90 day fans fam make sure you
stick with e.t because we are covering
it all i will see you next time
[Music]